[Musique]
la la la la la la
me passent et la rivière dernier besoin
d'un levier grand-maman mondial i
philippe effet à la lidia mois la pesca
bout maupiti
[Musique]
wouah mes enfants vos travail aux gains
sont peints akwaba abidjan bonjour et
bienvenue
je suis vivek vivek eux john banquiers
professionnel avec 15 ans d'expérience
et je viens de l'île maurice et l'île
maurice
on compense surtout très souvent avec le
paradis paradis sur terre la plage le
soleil et le légendaire sourire des
mauriciens et comme dit bob swaim ghost
writer dans la drive offre un parti
c'est un de nos atouts et on veut garder
cette image est revenu à la chanson que
j'ai fait fredonner
c'est une de mes ancêtres
une des ancêtres de nombreux mauriciens
qui sont venus de la chine de la grande
péninsule
l'inde et surtout l'afrique travailler
dur très dur pour gagner leur vie
et comme dit la chanson faut travailler
pour gagner son pain
elle a travaillé très dur pour que moi
aujourd'hui je suis ici pour que ces
engins petit fils ilia petites filles
puissent un jour avoir une éducation
saine devenir médecin pilote ou tout
simplement professeurs bien sûr on a
tous de belles voitures
ils ont un bon mari une bonne femme
plusieurs copines est ok ça va mais à
maurice on n'a pas de ressources
naturelles
c'est le human capital qui était
important et quand je vous ai dit
majorité sont des professionnels des
jeunes et on a perdu un certain moment
mais après que j'ai analysé les valeurs
des valeurs très humaine qui étaient là
des décennies mais pour la suite
c'est toujours là mais peut-être s'est
perdu ici il ya plus le matérialisme qui
a pris le dessus
c'est surtout on est très peu le voisin
on ne parle pas vers autrui
on est toujours figé devant son
ordinateur sur facebook dans son travail
ses activités mais qu'est ce que prêche
toutes les grandes religions c'est
surtout l'amour pour le tri qu'ils
soient africains et européens jaunes
blancs ou extra c'est surtout d'aller
vers les autres
c'est surtout pour aider et pour la
suite se rapprocher de dieu où le divin
quoi bon en même temps c'était surtout à
l'heure que et en tout petit matou betty
excusez moi un moment nous disait même
si tu as faim tu as très fin et en un
seul morceau de pain la côte et toi et à
ton voisin qui est plus pauvre que toi
portage portage et protégeant crocs
quand tu gagnes rend complice et surtout
n'attend rien en retour
je travaille j'ai mes propres objectifs
mes clients une belle vie voiture un bon
salaire très important longeant pour
vous dire dans le monde matériel et
c'est pas toujours un poteau mais vu que
j'ai senti que les valeurs s'éroder dans
mon pays c'est là d'où est venue l'idée
de créer brahim paradise braille
c'est surtout pour aider les jeunes
voyants malvoyants ou non voyants les
aveugles de mon pays et nous surtout
l'objectif est surtout d'aider
les jeunes aveugles de 3 à 18 ans en le
on va le et des livres en braille qui
sont gratuits pour eux qu'on fait venir
de l'étranger et à travers le soutien
d'hommes richesses pose la poste de
maurice le concept est très simple on
n'a pas eu besoin de sous on a eu
simplement une idée j'ai une idée
j'en ai parlé avec des amis très sympa
des gens qui sont très committers et vu
note le temps qu'on se tourne à lou ann
e au boulot et nos hôtes engagements
personnels respectifs
je voulais créer quelque chose tu t'en
en faisant notre boulot ce surtout
potager notre temps avec des gens de
notre communauté des gens qui sont
surtout vulnérable et on peut pas tout
faire à loger se choisit les jeunes
aveugles et les malvoyants là l'exemple
est très simple très simple si
l'organisation disons je vais prendre le
cameroun s'est formée à abidjan et on
sait qu'il ya des jeunes aveugles à
travers le caméroun les membres en
principe comme nous on le fait on a un
site facebook brahim paradise hockey les
parents de l'enfant va voir sur notre
profil de notre rôle quels sont les
livres qui sont surtout qu'ils sont là
disons si l'enfant veut le petit
chaperon rouge en braille formate la
version braille ok le lendemain - ou un
de ses membres ou quelqu'un au camerou
une disons si c'est là il va déposer le
livre à la puce la plus proche d'eux et
ainsi de suite la poste va livrer à la
poste centrale pour un aspect
sécuritaire et pour la suite l'après
centrale va livrer sa disons à cocody et
où l'enfant habite et saison facteur qui
va le livrer à domicile et tu ça c'est
gratuit bien sûr rien structure il ya
des délais respectés il ya tout un genre
de
sécurité qu'il faut vérifier c'est aussi
simple que ça et le lendemain plutôt
dans une quinzaine de jours
aussitôt que l'électeur termine sa
lecture c'est toujours ses parents qui
va suivre le même procédé
al'inverse va retourner le livre et le
livre a atterri hier à la librairie
l'objectif c'est surtout d'éduquer ses
enfants vulnérables bien sûr dans mon
pays on a des institutions spécialisées
on a le gouvernement on a des gens très
correct qui êtes
mais c'est surtout des lacunes en tant
que le moins professionnel et en les
côtoyant j'ai vu ces lacunes
c'est fou ça je voulais les combler
c'est gratuit il ya une mobilité réduite
pour l'enfant aussi n'a pas se déplacer
et tous les livres sont sur le sua page
facebook et le librairie n'est pas
fermée de 8h30 du matin à 16 heures et
on n'emploie pas de staff on le fait
bénévolement vous surtout que nous donc
un professionnel de notre propre fait un
bon coup
je ne sais pas le droit ex textura mais
on s'engage réellement pas seulement
pour prendre des photos qu'on fait de la
bienfaisance et de le poster sur
facebook non c'est surtout de francs
seront donnés sincèrement donné et c'est
ça que on essaie de changer pour revenir
sur un de nos valeurs primordiales c'est
surtout surtout poulain mots de l'autrui
est comme ça on a d'autres initiatives
que j'ai initié excusez moi j'ai une
gauche patrick lowe de ses enfants
bondier l'enfant monde y est c'est kit
kids of god
c'est aussi simple que on partage de la
nourriture un certain moment d'un mois
pendant une fête le ramadan
ou celle à noël ou la pac une des fêtes
que tous les mauriciens vont célébrer
ensemble et là l'idée aussi simple que
ce qu'on protège de la nouriture oui
mais le concept c'est chez elle en che
story potager un déjeuner potager une
histoire hélas l'audience qu on surtout
on va aller vers kiss et les
travailleuses du sexe les anciens
toxicomanes les extras aux prisonniers
les gens atteints du vih/sida et tous
les gens qui ont été rejetées pour les
familles pour une quelconque raison on
n'essaie pas de les juger parce que je
suis pas là pour ça et on n'essaie pas
de les réinsérer dans la société
parce que je suis pas fort mais mes mots
ne sont pas formés poussant mais
simplement on partage une tente où plus
d'une et autant de notre temps avec eux
on essaie de comprendre pourquoi elles
sont là on essaie de le dire ils sont
toujours aussi importants que nous dans
une société qui peut-être perdre ses
valeurs
on le donne surtout de cette chaleur
humaine est aussi retour retour de leur
dignité
c'est 100 et pour nous c'est surtout et
c'est surtout un portage notre valeur et
en dernier je vais surtout pour les sur
une autre ong que jette c'est la society
for the wall faire d'edf pour les
enfants sous et là c'était un vrai
challenge au début j'ai travaillé avec
quarante jeunes 40 jeunes sourds
c'était pas trop facile en tant que
jeune ouais c'est top je vais du social
extra mais pour pouvoir communiquer avec
eux c'est un vrai challenge et à la
faire je peux dire que je suis sorti
gagnant de ces quarante jeunes où on a
pris des valeurs humaines on a fait du
peace building
moi même je suis pour la suite j'ai dû
faire des motivés chantôme
peace building pourquoi parce que les
maurice est une société hybride où
vivent plusieurs communautés issues de
plusieurs pays et c'est surtout cette
paix on veut garder
c'est un laboratoire pour le monde où il
ya toutes les composantes et tout ce qui
se passe à travers le monde nous
influence si c'est bon ou si c'est
mauvais et là c'était surtout surtout
d'un essai jeunes même s'ils vivent avec
un handicap de le faire sentir qu'ils
sont importants qu'ils sont surtout ils
peuvent contribuer à la paix sociale et
en même temps de les éduquer de les
motiver et c est là on l'a on a
développé leur passe-temps comme une
profession et on a fait du social et
peint deux activités et pendant une
année le programme c'est le duke of
edinburgh jawad on a dû se bagarrer avec
les officiers du ministère tout pour le
dire non on veut faire ça y est on bien
du potentiel activision et voilà et
depuis le mois dernier ils ont pu être
ils ont reçu leur bronze à wad et c'est
une c est une première
outre 23 des jeunes vivant avec un
handicap ont reçu le certificat et la
médaille avec le ministre de l' de la
jeunesse et des sports
bref ce sont des activités qu'on fait à
maurice en tant que professionnel
j'essaie de trouver du temps et c'est
pour ça je suis là aujourd'hui pour vous
dire vous tous qui sont là jeunes moins
jeunes les jeunes ce n'est pas
nécessaire d'avoir beaucoup de sous pour
commencer que ce soit l'entrepreneuriat
ou un truc de bienfaisance c'est
simplement d'avoir une idée de rêver
surtout très très important parce que
moi même j'étais du pas toujours banque
et j'ai un bon salaire mais j'ai dû me
bagarrer moi aussi contagieuse quand
j'étais jeune j'étais toujours un
rebelle dans l'âme mais il ya eu
toujours mes parents ma maman qui m'a
guidé les amis et on peut dire les
anciens et pour vous dire le succès
aussi c'est pas mesuré à votre voiture
votre maison ou combien dessous vous
dépensez mais c'est surtout une
satisfaction intérieure et surtout quand
vous faites cela bien sûr je suis pas
super même si je suis ici aujourd'hui
c'est simplement je suis comme roussiens
venant du nil et qu'on veut surtout dire
aux jeunes qu'ils sont là d'aller de
l'avant
et si vous tombez n'hésitez pas de vous
relever tomber en gros tomber fait des
erreurs
c'est là qu'ont appris qu'on apprend
surtout et c'est pas nécessairement voir
des amis haut placés
parce que je sais que l'afrique aussi à
beaucoup de soucis mais simplement avoir
une idée des atouts dream c'est ça et on
n'est pas bien sûr on veut pas être des
leaders du futur ou des futurs leaders
mais des vidéos du prison et je vais
demander surtout aux dirigeants
africains de donner la chance aux
ivoiriens aux autres africains deux
croient en la jeunesse est aussi je vais
terminer surtout pas 7,6 au fait voilà
pour moi la satisfaction comme j'ai dit
c'est pas nécessairement l'argent c'est
une petite fille aveugle dans une des
écoles spécialisées à ne voit pas mais
c'est cette paix antérieurs la thérapie
n'est ce qu'on consent qu'on lui donne
un livre et les bénédictions du sa maman
des parents qui nous surtout motive à
aller de l'avant
je vais tout simplement terminer d'être
humble dans la vie je vous fais avec de
l'humilité
parce que ce qu'on fait des récompenses
qu'on reçoit a mûri j'ai eu plusieurs
récompenses même venir ici c'est une
autre récompense
il faut rester humble c'est ça très
important est de toujours avoir les
pieds bien ancrés sur la terre et la
tête dans les étoiles rêver merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]